ich fühle die hubschraubertypen 58 kiowa
beim österreichischen bundesheer seit
2009 diesem hubschraubertyp zeichnet
sich speziell aus weil sie bewaffnet
werden kann mit einem maschinengewehr
welches nach vorne gerichtet werden kann
und dadurch eben auch vorher
unterstützung aus der luft geben kann
für bodentruppen
es ist einsatzgebiet wird von nur uns
abgedeckt und sonst keinem anderen
hubschrauber im österreichischen
bundesheer
das kann der hubschrauber ausgestattet
werden mit seinem wärmebild gerät
versuchen rettungseinsätze kann man als
passagier transporter verwendet werden
und auch schneller ladungen aus der luft
mit spezialeinheiten auf sehr kleinen
mengen plane plätzen durchbringen
die karriere eines militärpiloten hat
nicht damit auf tausenden scheinen den
händen hält oder einfach einsatz belohnt
wird sondern man kann sich vielfältig
weiterentwickeln
man kann zum beispiel sich als
fluglehrer weiterentwickeln wenn man und
offizier ist oder eben wie ich es
gemacht habe auf die militärakademie zu
gehen um in weiterer folge von staffel
kommunen zu werden oder weitere für
unsere führungspositionen zu erreichen
körperliche fitness ist montags
militärpiloten extrem wichtig wir werden
jedes jahr im heeresspital auf herz und
nieren durchgecheckt und auch in
sportlicher hinsicht überprüft
deswegen ist es eines jeden piloten
eigene verantwortung sich körperlich fit
zu halten
wir haben jede menge möglichkeiten das
auch zu tun zwischen den flügen oder
auch an tagen an denen nicht geflogen
wird
es gibt die möglichkeit laufen zu gehen
oder ins fitnessstudio zu gehen oder
schwimmen zu gehen und ich glaube nicht
dass es einen anderen beruf gibt an dem
man dienstzeit sport machen kann
stellungspflichtige burschen aber auch
mädels die extrem technik interessiert
sind und immer schon einen drahtzieherei
gehabt haben sind beim bundesheer genau
richtig aufgehoben weil nur hier findet
man diese spezielle art von extremer
fliegerei verhandlungs stechen die man
sonst in der zivil finden würde